today's starting pitcher for the tigers
is casey mize obviously casey gonna set
the tone here early so two on two out
and now it's up to jk here comes the o2
swung on and missed
cave strikes out
walking a hit batter in the end do no
harm by aida in four starts three-and-oh
very good 3.18 e-r-a victor reyes at the
plate the one-two pounded to
right-center that's going to get down
and that's going to go up against the
wall reyes has got good speed he's a
long strider he's going to go for three
and he will get there with a head first
slide a lead off triple for reyes be
interesting to see how majeda pitches
here to miguel cabrera
on the ground there it is
his 2 000th
career hit as a tiger joining that
exclusive club
and it brings in reyes for the first run
of the day
he joins cobb and caline garenger
heilman crawford travel and whittaker
and the old english d pretty select
group of great tigers and uh miguel
belongs in that group to levine against
the first hit the tying run 90 feet away
for kepler and that gets away to the
backstop here comes gonzalez with the
tying run mize he fired another one in
the dirt
a wild pitch to tie the game bounces in
front of home plate or in the side of
and
griner cannot get it
so gonzales scores the tie of the game
bolanco leads off in a 1-1 game
polanco deep down to the right field
line that balls up and gone
and the second time is the charm for
jorge polanco well looked like he got a
fastball and turned on it home run
number three for polanco and it's a two
to one twins lead tyler alexander takes
over on the mound here in the fourth
inning he's two and two to lamont way
junior and he strikes him out to start
his day it's a way to come into the ball
game right there
one hitter one out now the number nine
hitter alex avelich the 3-2
swung on and missed
back-to-back punch-outs to start tyler
alexander's day here in the fourth it'll
be
candelario
sends one to deep right
back goes kepler and that's gone
candelario does it again and we are tied
at two a five-game hitting streak for
candelario
includes his fourth home run of the year
you know chef that ball was hit so high
that it was kind of deceiving but that
ball was hit a long way
to right field just like that can he
ties this ball game and that's a huge
plus picks up his team right there miata
out there first fifth inning 63 pitches
41 strikes
surprised him
strikeout number five
two strikes to paredes
and a fastball gets him two down
strikeout number six back-to-back
strikeouts
jonathan scope who singled his last time
up but struck out in the first the 2-1
hammered to left stay fair
and that ball's gone
a home run for jonathan scope he turned
on that baby and it's 3-2 tigers yeah i
didn't know if that ball was going to
stay fair [ __ ] but it did
and uh
wow what a big hit right there big
moment for the tigers and joe jimenez
here in the seventh two away man on
first and the most dangerous hitter in
the minnesota lineup
the 1-2 got him swinging
nervous
not anymore
you just got the best out of joe jimenez
against minnesota's best to quiet the
twins tigers with a one-run lead will
now face former tiger farmhand caleb
thielbaugh
bonifacio the pinch-hitter for stewart
here in the seventh
and gets him to chase a fastball one
down right-handed batting catcher
fastball up and in gets a swing in a
minute that's 92 good location
back-to-back strikeouts for theobar
now
strike three called and theobar with a
one two three seventh inning striking
out the side buck farmer gonna take over
on the mound for joe they've had him
tied up all day long through the
breaking ball there gregory soto for the
second straight day it's gonna be ryan
jefferson 2-1
and that's a base hit for jeffers just
his fifth hit of the year
he keeps the inning and the game alive
from minnesota soto 14 pitches deep two
outs and a man on the 2-1 to kepler
to center field for jacoby jones and the
tigers have their first three-game sweep
of the twins since september of 2016.
there's a little dancing going on
there's a little smiling going on
detroit is 500 on the year
after beating the twins three in a row
on a good-looking weekend here at
comerica park